так виглядав Копенгаген 2 липня 2011
року після катастрофічних злив вулицями
данської столиці плавали мертві щури
працівники сміттєзбірника потруїлися від
випарів а один навіть помер від
зараження крові за останні ість років
такі потужні зливи траплялися у
Копенгагені чотири рази стічна
каналізація не справлялася з такими
обсягами води подібні зливи стаються і в
інших великих містах урбаністи шукають
розв'язання проблеми Копенгаген
знаходиться попереду міст які
трансформуються адже зміна клімату
робить опити дедалі більш
непередбачуваними та інтенсивними деякі
протиповиневі концепції передбачають
затоплення спортивних майданчиків їдемо
у серце Копенгагена аби
дізнатися як захистити таке місто від
повини
ще пять років тому цього дерева тут не
було замість нього тут стояв би ймовірно
якийсь позашляховик у заторі
цю площу перепланували колись тут була
жвава Кільцева розв'язка тепер це ліс
посеред міста це частина концепції
перетворити Копенгаген на свого роду
гігантську губку після руйнівної повені
2011 політики хотіли щоб воду можна було
дуже швидко відвестити з міста якимось
розумним способом чи можна було б
розширити каналізацію або перебудувати
її геть інакше
чи можна було б поєднати це зпрагнення
міста стати більш зеленим з більшим
біорозмаїттям і більшою кількістю місця
де люди могли б
зустрічатися команда расмусина
перетворила це кільцеве перехрестя на
Невидимий захист від повиний
це маленький ставок в якому ми можемо
зберігати дощову воду якщо випадає
більше дощів то ми маємо тут через
дорогу ще більше таких ставків які
зрештою поєднані з
[музика]
морем ці невеликі з'єднані між собою
ставки розташовані по всьому місту для
накопичення надлишків дощової
води є також інші концепції для
зберігання води наприклад озеленені
дахи або такі сучасні Стоки в районах з
високим ризиком затоплення все це
позначено на карті яка показує де саме
місто може бути затоплене під час
потужних злив частина інвестицій
вартістю приблизно 2 мільрди євро
розташована на глибині 20 Мет під землею
це основа проти повиневої концепції
данської столиці тунель з такою щільною
міською територією ви не можете
розв'язати проблему просто екологічними
рішеннямиклан ка працює над величезним
проектом тунелю для міської служби
водопостачання ви можете робити все
можливе на поверхні так можна відводити
легки дощ але коли він справді лле як з
відра необхідна велика система немає
способу вивести воду в гавань не
побудувавши такий
тунель тунель має 3 м в діаметрі і
тягнеться через місто на 18 кмет
скеровуючи дощову воду в
Порт Але у нього є й інша функція Вода
може зберігатися тут а не в
каналізаційній системі і повільно
виводитися в
гавань
це стабілізує рівень і якість води
під час нового шторму Тунелі знову
заповнюються якщо станеться сильний
шторм який затопить вулиці ми просто
відкриємо тунель і зможемо перекачати
всю воду в гавань вода на вулицях все
одно буде Я маю на увазі що вони не
будуть Гать сухими але це дозволить нам
опустити рівень води з півметра або до
10 максимум 20
см і скільки води може витримати ця
система кількість води яку можна
транспортувати визначає насосна станція
а насос здатен перекачати 20 000 літрів
на секунду як тільки надходить штурмовий
сигнал і вода починає стікати вулицями
насосна станція запускається і відкачує
воду
їдемо до старого парку в центрі міста
тут є й озеленені території і
заасфальтовані парк складається з трьох
рівнів на першому розарії під яким
зберігається
вода цей резервуар також служить
резервом води для парку в посушливі
періоди коли цей резервуар буде
заповнений Ми почнемо заповнювати
спортивний майданчик який ви бачите там
ця водойма глибша за решту території
парку тому вода автоматично збирається
тут коли резервуар заповниться він
виглядатиме
так А ще є протиповинева
[музика]
стіна коли йде Злива тут підіймається
стіна і ця територія позаду мене
перетворюється на величезний басейн який
накопичує стічні
води та чи здатні ці заходи впоратися з
найгіршим
сценарієм ди може налетіти ще потужніший
шторм ніж будь-який раніше це може
статися до того ж зміна клімату
продовжуватиметься завжди можуть випасти
опади які будуть ще
сильнішими від цього ніхто не захищений
на 100% але певний захист є інвестиції у
захист протипований порівнюються з
ризиками від потенційних
збитків і це той рівень інвестицій який
ми готові робити Угу інші міста
безумовно дуже уважно спостерігають за
копенгагеном оцінюючи скільки
коштуватиме інвестувати нині щоб
зменшити шкоду від зміни клімату в
майбутньому